[Aplausos]
então caí aqui é assim a toque mas no ar
mas não andamos no ar mas não é
vá eu tô isso porque eu sou assim agora
para explicar porque eu sou assim agora
tá em recuar 21 anos atrás no tempo
então para onde a china não é luz rotten
o enredo sonhar mais velha 16 anos
animados no segmento só pelas artes
então até seu que começar um novo curso
escolar
no colégio a mão do porto saiu mal mas
como você achava isso muito rigoroso
então é automática e eu não gostava
daquilo
então toda a gente me dizia a patton que
as cartas porque assim quando precisava
pintar as paredes lá em casa todo o
estado entre ontem quando precisa fazer
um rock como no restaurante com a minha
nova empresa tu fazes e fica o teu
portfolio sul em toda assim pois quando
quiser ganhar dinheiro sem um futuro
muito longínquo pode sair problema
nenhum então eu não quis saber o que
toda a gente dizia e efetivamente
criados
mas para fazer isso não podia continuar
no colégio mauá no porto que vive
criando um vácuo machos com na área
portuguesa e né pra mudar em parada
colégio nossa senhora do rosário onde os
que efetivamente o curso arte pronto
acaba o curso arte onde eu sei que vou
fazer agora o que vou fazer agora não
faz e vai a arte não quer pintar a
parede não quer fazê lo a tempo pois
meus amigos não quer fazer isso eu quero
ter uma vida então é porque eu comecei a
pensar aí que eu gosto verdadeiramente
animação
então ele voltava eu colocava os
domingos das 8 da manhã envolveu nove
sim eu tô achando fazer isso mas eu
queria mesmo aquilo queria mesmo
animação e animação que eu queria então
resolvi seguir o meu curso néis mais na
escola superior de música e artes do
espetáculo então seguir tecnologias da
comunicação multimídia que não só tem
animação
como também tem design tem programação
está em fotografia também adoro então aí
comecei a descobrir as várias áreas
damos média pronto era ótimo mas cavar
tocas só quisesse animação aqui em
portugal a funcionar porque era sempre
animação em portugal esquece mas tem que
sair de portugal de certeza absoluta
enquanto 88 anos depois vai derrotar o
curso depois prontidão mostrar lá fora
tem problema nenhum então assim realizou
um dos meus primeiros sonhos que foi o
projeto final do curso no projeto final
por curso eu posso fazer uma animação
uma curta de animação ou seja finalmente
tinha liberdade para fazer o que eu
quisesse mostrar o que eu
verdadeiramente valia
então juntei uma das colegas meus e
nenhum nós podia ficar desvalorizadas
então juntamos as idéias dos trechos e
optamos por fazer uma curta de animação
de seis minutos e eu era responsável
pela por uma das personagens
então pode explicar mais ou menos como é
um processo de animação e como é k
animação é tão espetacular para mim vou
começar por explicar que está em uma
idéia nossa imagina uma personagem com
sua história tem que ter perfil tem que
ter caráter tentei tudo então uma pessoa
imaginar personagem possa começar com os
primeiros voz começa a passar papel
começa a ver aí como é que vai ser só
com essa crise pronto tá sabendo do fato
legal a europa exemplifica gosta de você
e eu tenho que ser cristão não pode
agressivo meu deus como é que vamos
fazer um dragão que traga um cliente não
está não existem
então vou pensar meu deus que eu vou
fazer pronto os vossos dos vossos dos
moços passamos para a
tridimensionalidade
começamos a ver o problema e começamos a
morl várias personagens e ela que
começar bem a vida então quando texto
ramos ainda mais vida ganha o meu está
aqui uma personagem está aqui este ser
conviver
se nós quisermos vencer pode viver então
nós pensamos nas opções e e movimentos e
eu repito desenvolve toda uma
personalidade como as pessoas conseguem
identificar
vai lançar o tele tá bom né
[Música]
a culpa
e prometeu um cano chefe da minha curta
de animação não posso mostrar tudo não é
quem quiser ver graças a deus somos
agora não foi assinado pelos prêmios
festa e vamos tarde não se vê dia 7
alguém quiser ver a minha curta e
levantar então desta maneira eu ia
fazendo as curtas e fazendo o meu
trabalho
sócrates eo eu sempre fui trabalhando ao
longo da faculdade são gostei de coisas
a fazer e também plantou a gente dizia
animação anima são todas concentradas
conseguir então eu sempre gostei de
explorar outras áreas
então você explorar as fotografias e
companhia ser chamada para fazer alguns
trabalhos culturais
então num certo dia lindo dia de sol
recebeu uma chamada do rui pedro
oliveira quer dizer olha eu tô aqui com
um projeto é preciso que venha conosco a
polônia para desenvolvermos esse projeto
nós cremos que tudo foi documentado em
vídeo como sujeito na boa viagem para
bonito paga quer fazer o que eu gosto
tenho no brasil ficam e os papos online
isso pra mim eu tenho a primeira linha
vou falar e entra no site da reunião eu
por mim nos mais um dos maiores estúdios
de animação da europa atinge toda a
gente a animar a minha volta e então que
isto que se passa com o meu trabalho
fotográfico nu maio da primeira longa
metragem de animação portuguesa e assim
do nada que eu acabar o curso penta tudo
mais um projetinho acreditava que sua
visita é isso que eu quero eu tento
ficar aqui enquanto vai voltar a
portugal e eu sendo obrigado olha temos
que encontrar outra fez por causa de tal
material e temos que encontrar o vídeo e
temos que nos encontrar em riste por
aqui então eu não parava de chatear até
que logo estarão mim em pronto e uma fé
trabalhava eu e meus momento tô num
projecto inacreditável que espero que
toda a gente vai ver pronto assim do
nada todo mundo maior dos projectos que
portugal tem pronto um lava em alto mar
pronto mas eu já vou contar a história
do filme
então é o que é que este grande filme
que estou a falar
então meu lema é uma menina de 12 anos
que infelizmente perdeu a mãe
mas amanhã de morrer deixou uma história
sobre um grande mistério
então eu ainda achava que ao descobrir o
mistério é estava cobrando mistério era
sobre um grande pássaro branco que frau
para não passar em branco
achava que eu ia salvar a família dela
porque o pai estava em grande sofrimento
por causa do luto e ela achava que nunca
ia salvar a família dela então ela
juntamente com o seu irmão tomate com
raiva de mim muito curioso muito curioso
e mais um em uma mina cuja verdadeira
identidade chamas conhecidas também ver
o filme vai em busca de citar o grande
mistério e onde em fátima quando durante
o centenário este filme é um tributo às
operações do da prisão de fátima aos
três pastorinhos e vai então passar
nestas celebrações
vejam só na suíça
[Música]
o forró não vir a índia off to end of
peace and other
[Música]
não dizendo isto uma produção portuguesa
conseguiu também contar com grande
personalidade portuguesas como o nosso
grande mérito foi uma cena que vai ser
eu quem vai fazer a banda sonora do
nosso filme
podemos também contar com josé mourinho
para a voz off e dalila carmo também
passava só vi as outras pessoas têm
esperado
então pronto eu assim vá pentear a cabo
curso conseguir nessa altura certa
conseguir acabar o curso na altura certa
consegui participar na primeira longa
metragem de animação portuguesa como é
que isso é possível
então agora acreditam tal como eu que os
sonhos podem tornar se livrar
então é isso que eu vou mostrar uma
coisinha que eu tive a grande sorte de
presenciar a semana passada fui ao
terceiro aniversário da hydro não sei se
vocês conhecem e tive o grande prazer de
ouvir marc ecko verde dada a sessão no
vermelho e por presenciar uma
demonstração muito distante que mostram
o quanto os sonhos vala
então assim que uma nota 20 horas tem
essa nota inteira só só ninguém mais
quer em novos 20 horas barra pronto
quem é continuar com essa nota 20 horas
a campanha que continua crescendo notas
internas
quem é continuar a festa dos 20 anos
porque vocês continuam crescendo é
continuar acreditando às 20 horas porque
há o aval exatamente a mesma coisa
pessoal ter sido pisada é só ter sido a
mais votada só tenho pena está
exatamente como as rações
os valores podem ser uma parte pesados
rospide o que faço mas vocês nunca nos
incentiva ações promoções valem o que
valem e se eu na minha vida também são
21 anos não é assim tanto tempo mas é a
minha vida
confie tá no meio de um grande projeto
com o resto vocês também conseguem
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]